candid
truth what is up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it there was a lot of
Christian people right-wing people that
thought Trump he's the Messiah he's
going to come he's going to change the
world he's going to make America great
again and I think they're in a I think
they're in for a wakeup call when you
look at what Trump just posted today
people are starting to ask questions
this is Trump's official Instagram and
if you haven't watched this video
prepare to be shocked this is live I'm
not censoring the comment section that's
on Instagram but we're going to look at
the comment section because it's pretty
crazy that even Trump fans are saying I
should have voted for Kamala like people
are starting to have a change of heart
about Trump and it's only February look
at this video
[Music]
Don is com to set you free bringing the
light for all to see no more tunnels no
more fear CLA is finally here CLA
shining bright golden future a brand new
light feast and Dan the deal is done
Trump are number one Trump are shining
bright golden future a br new light and
dance the deal is done Trump Gaza number
one crazy so so what is up with all the
golden idol stuff of trump there's a
video if you haven't checked it out on
candid truth check it out it says the
deception is greater than we thought and
it has Trump on there it shows the
golden calf it shows all his fans with
the patch on their ear showing that they
are idolizing this guy they're just
being deceived Trump is a pawn he is
another puppet in the whole game and I
want to show you um just some of these
comments in the comments SE I'll try to
expand on these and like I said I can't
edit the comment section because this is
live so there are some you know language
that will not be suitable for children
but it says this has to be the most dis
disrespectful and toned deaf thing a
president could do 111,000 likes on it
now remember everybody right now is kind
of liking Trump even the people that
used to not like Trump are now liking
Trump so this isn't just like the haters
when he was in the first term but look
at this um I'm right-wing and what the
hell is this so This right-wing dude is
like dude what is this this says this
video is truly horrifying they are
dancing and celebrating over the bodies
of innocent children this is crazy uh as
a trump supporter horrible post Trump
supporters are now saying like we regret
voting for you look okay maybe I should
have voted for Kamala somebody says I'm
a trump supporter and what the is this
crazy this is the worst thing I've seen
on the internet all year Trump I voted
for you for you to have a better economy
better laws and take care of our country
stay focused on the future and our
nation I don't create obstacles blah
blah obviously he does not like this
either WTF is this somebody says how
does a sitting president post something
like this and there everybody's just
going off on this and notice it says
right here comments on this post have
been limited I don't know if that's set
by Trump set by Instagram or what but um
things are starting to get a little
weird so I have a hypothesis this is
something that I said A week ago and
again last night before this video came
out I want to show you my hypothesis
because I believe that Satan is so
cunning and crafty and
deceptive that we're we're all like
being misdirected by the magician by the
sorcerers and these people this is the
hegelian dialect they play Both Sides
they're playing left and right they're
playing red and blue they're playing
Republican Democrat Satan is playing
good cop bad cop and while he's getting
your attention over here he's doing
something else over here it's slight of
hand so I'm going to play a clip from um
a week ago on our stream and I want you
to hear what I say here we know Satan
plays both
sides what if all this is purposeful to
make Trump look like the Antichrist
literally because if like you're saying
dispensationalists they're looking for
who is the one that was wounded and had
a deadly wound and was healed you know
Trump supposedly got shot uh he's on the
coin of Israel he's going to make a
covenant he's to talk about peace and
safety what if all lives go to Trump he
is him he's the Antichrist he fits
everything then the true Antichrist
comes which is Satan Satan is going to
appear what what we're waiting for
before Christ returns is Satan to
manifest in our world as a cosmic savior
a supernatural being more deceptive than
Trump ever could be more deceptive than
the pope ever could be more deceptive
than any human human being could ever be
because now you're talking about an
angel of Light who's doing signs and
wonders and miracles and healing the
world and getting rid of pandemics and
stopping uh natural disasters quote
unquote natural disasters and wars and
all these things what if he comes and
kills Trump the
Antichrist and everybody's like this is
Jesus this supernatural being that
literally killed the one man Antichrist
that we've been looking
for so this is this is crazy because the
way I understand prophecy I do not
believe that we are looking for a oneman
Antichrist I don't believe that all
these Left Behind movies all the
mainstream uh Christianity after the um
The Counter Reformation or after the
Reformation The Counter Reformation came
and they were trying to misdirect people
from seeing that the Roman Catholic
Church the papacy the the Roman Empire
is the Antichrist system when you see
the word Antichrist in the Bible it's
always plural it says there are many
Antichrist even now the Antichrist
spirit it's never pointing out to a one
man ruler and I believe it's it's
positions people are are disposable even
if Pope Francis is in the seat now in a
year he could not be in the seat so you
can't point at Pope Francis and say he's
the Antichrist because someone can take
his place but whoever is in the I
whoever is sitting in that seat saying I
am Christ on Earth I am God on when
where is that crown that says VI F day
which means the substitute of Christ on
Earth they are Antichrist and the whole
system is
Antichrist but I believe that there's a
tons of propaganda out there this uh
Counter Reformation propaganda that says
no we're looking for a one man in the
future some political leader that's
charismatic and does all these things
well first I want to show you this clip
where I said this last night on Brad's
stream on strange normal I think Satan
is got this whole thing man it's a
puppet show he plays both sides the
hegelian
dialect he is it's it's a slight of hand
it's
misdirection because what I think is
everybody's G to at first think Trump's
awesome like man things are changing
things are great actually things are
going better gas is better uh getting
rid of all the woke stuff and all this
stuff but then they're going to start
recognizing wait a minute he he's hand
inand with Elon who wants to microchip
our brains he is okay so you get the
point now check this out so I just asked
chat gbt what is basically the
mainstream idea of who the what the
markers are for the Antichrist check
this out it says he will rise from a
revived Roman Empire
that's in Daniel 9:26 or 9 27 now I
don't agree with everything this is
going to say I'm just telling you what
the majority of the Christian World
believes that's the whole point that's
why it's so important to understand
prophecy to know that we're going to be
here during the tribulation we're not
going to be raptured out of here that um
all kinds of stuff that the that the
Antichrist is not one man but a
system and that Satan is going to come
on the scenes as Christ as a cosmic
Christ he's going to be doing lying
signs and wonders Miracle working demons
he's going to have Supernatural power to
bring down fire from heaven and all
these things how are we going to be able
to resist something that powerful we've
never been faced with a supernatural
being who is basically like a superhero
and can do everything from healings if
you don't believe Satan can heal go talk
to a new Ager who's doing raiky and
Crystal healing all this stuff Satan has
crazy amount of power that he can do
lying signs and wonders he can put an
ailment on somebody remove that ailment
and now they've been healed quote
unquote healed right so this is going to
be a being that is Supernatural and is
going to
end the Antichrist Reign but this is
what I think this is what I believe
Satan is in control of everything this
is his world he's the God of this world
he's working through the the governments
of this system it says we we battle not
against flesh and blood but against
principalities against the powers and
the rul the rulers of the darkness of
this age of this world so he's putting
all the people in place preparing them
to do to bring about one world religion
One World Government the New World
Order so Trump is just a pawn he's a
player in the game now all the
Christians are looking for a Onan
Antichrist before Christ returns so
Satan cannot come if he's going to
really deceive the world he can't just
come as Christ right now because he
would be he would be going ahead of the
game right Christians are all looking
for an antichrist so Satan can't step
out on the scenes as Christ yet because
we're still looking for an antichrist
get
it if he came out on the scene right now
as Christ we would all say wait a minute
this isn't Christ this is the Antichrist
because the Antichrist has to come first
so Satan is going to set up a fake
Antichrist you hear this and and while
all and it's going to be obvious it's
going to match all the markers that
people are looking for in the the
understanding they have of Prophecy so
it says right here that he'll confirm a
seven-year Covenant with
Israel well I think that's very
interesting because it says Israel group
mints Trump coin
to honor
Jerusalem Trump is on a coin for
Jerusalem for Israel and and his face is
Right There by King Cyrus why is an
American president on a coin for Israel
so here's marker number one people are
going to be like wait a minute see
everybody's gonna everybody's going to
embrace him at first they're going to
embrace Trump and say look he's getting
rid of everything this is great but then
they're going to say wait a minute we
we've been deceived by the
Antichrist wait a minute he's matching
all the markers it says he will break
the Covenant at midpoint so we haven't
got there yet um he will be a
charismatic political leader promising
peace okay has Trump is Trump a
charismatic leader yeah is he you know
his fans are idolizing him put a put a
patch on your ear and all this stuff
right he's charismatic and he's making
these funny tweets and all that kind of
stuff now what did Trump say we have
before us a rare
opportunity to bring security and
stability and peace to this region and
to its people okay security and peace is
what he said right and what does the
Bible say 1 Thessalonians 5:3 for when
they shall say peace and safety then
sudden destruction cometh upon them as
travail upon a woman with child and they
shall not Escape so Trump is openly
fulfilling these
prophecies that all Christians are
looking for in the Antichrist that we
know is supposed to come before the true
Christ and so Satan who's going to
appear as a supernatural being and wants
to deceive the world into thinking that
he's Christ has to set up a fake false
Antichrist decoy
first and it's all lining up he will
suffer a fatal head wound
and be
revived okay maybe I'm grasping here
reaching at straws but suppose and I
don't even believe this so I'm not even
falling for this catch-up pack on the
ear that was literally not even a scab a
week later when he's on TV he's like oh
yeah I'm a fast healer real fast healer
dude I have zits that last longer than
this guy's assault rifle ear wound
but either way he's been uh an attempted
assassination on him more than once
twice within a year's time and uh that's
when they really idolized him like a
messiah like yeah God's protecting him
look he survived assassination attempt
so maybe I'm reaching with this whole
deadly wound that he's you know he
revives from a fatal wound but even that
is
close then it say says he will claim to
be God and demand
worship he'll claim to be God all right
what do we see
here literally the golden idol like the
video I did a month or two ago whenever
it was when it says the deception is
greater than we thought and it shows
Trump with a golden calf and everybody
idolizing him with the the patch on
their ear I had no clue that he was
going to release a video showing him as
a golden image
remember there's going to be an image to
the Beast all people must bow before the
image of the Beast just like
Nebuchadnezzar right and and then here
it shows that in shops he's going to
have little Idols be sold dude this is
crazy if anyone if anyone is fitting the
the markers of what
mainstream Christians believe about the
Antichrist it's Trump he's even the last
Trump people put that together too like
that Christ is going to return at the
last Trump Christianity doesn't have a a
proper understanding of who the Beast is
they think the Beast is a person a
one-man person and they've always been
looking for him as an American president
is it is it Obama his name means
lightning from heaven and all this stuff
they've been looking for this they've
been Christians attention is looking for
a Onan anti- Christ and they're looking
for all these
markers and Trump just happens to be
filling these
markers um it says he will have a global
government and economic
control o okay he's going to have a
global government and economic control
look at this what does this
say it's Trump's World European leaders
divided on how to navigate this cacapon
I don't even know how to say that
cacaphony it's Trump's world this is
just one article Trump why does an
American president Trump travel all
around the world giving
speeches Jerusalem has his face on their
coin Trump Gaza he's going to turn Gaza
into this like tourist attraction he
will be empowered by Satan and he will
persecute Christians and Jews he will be
empowered by Satan who's his rightand
man Trump's right-hand man is Elon Musk
who wants to microchip your
brain and and what are all Christians
looking for they're looking for a Mark
that you take in your hand or in your
forehead and they think it's a microchip
I don't believe that I believe that the
mark of the beast is revelation is all
is all symbolic every prophecy that God
gave to man it was symbolic Joseph had a
dream about stars bowing down to stars
and stocks of wheat bowing down to wheat
and neuch
had a dream about an image and it was
about kingdoms Daniel had a dream about
beasts rising out of the sea and it was
about kingdoms uh Peter had a vision
about a sheep being let down with
unclean animals and it had nothing to do
with eating unclean animals Peter even
said I don't even know what this means
Lord I haven't eaten anything unclean
what does this mean and when you keep
reading people don't like to know this
truth but when you keep reading the
whole Vision was about do not call any
Gentile unclean it was all about stop
judging juding the Gentiles they're
grafted in so and and when you look at
Revelation there's not really going to
be a woman a harlot riding on a
seven-headed beast drinking blood that's
not it's symbolic a woman standing on
the moon clothed with the sun this is
all symbolic so Israel is symbolic we
are Israel there's neither Jew nor Greek
we're all one in Christ Jesus so when
you see Israel in in the Book of
Revelation it's talking about Believers
when you see Babylon in the in
Revelation Babylon doesn't even exist
anymore but it's a symbol or a sign of
the
wicked God's people are going to have a
seal in their foreheads do you think
that's a literal seal no I don't I don't
know any Christian that believes that
we're going to be literally having a
seal in our forehead but for some reason
they say that the the mark of the beast
oh that's definitely physical definitely
literal and physical but it's not it's
all about worship he's going to cause
the world to worship the beast in his
beliefs in his mind or in the works of
his hand you can take the mark of the
beast in your mind or in your hand if
you if you believe the system you took
it in your mind you believe it if you
don't believe it but you're going to do
it anyway like bowing to the image
instead of saying throw me in the fiery
furnace if you simply bow your body you
bow to the beast but you don't believe
in it you're taking it in the hand The
Works of the hand you can receive the
mark of the beast two ways you can only
receive the mark of of God the sign of
God in your mind because it's all about
belief his right-hand man is the dude
that wants to microchip your brain and
Trump is unrolling
Stargate Stargate is a uh a worldwide
surveillance
system that's 24-hour surveillance by AI
technology no human has to watch anymore
and the guy who started this who owns
Oracle the company Oracle Larry Ellison
said people will behave they'll be on
their best behavior when they're being
monitored 247 by
AI this is the dystopian world that we
are about to enter actually uh Trump
calls it the Golden Age and if you look
into what the golden age is this is what
all the occultists all the esoteric
writers like Alice Bailey and um some of
those other people said is the age of
Aquarius this is what the new age move
mement has been looking forward to and
they predicted that it would be in 2025
Alice Bailey said that in 2025 there
would be the externalization of the
hierarchy meaning there would be an an
external manifestation of Fallen Angels
demons among our world and what are we
seeing today quote unquote drones
everywhere we're seeing the military say
that we communicate with non-human
intelligences first they said we we see
UFOs every day then they said said we're
communicating with them now they're
picking up crafts that look like eggs
and we're going to do a show on what
does that mean what what symbolically is
where is all this going um according to
the esoteric writings with the egg and
people talking to these divine feminine
beings this is all part of the big plan
Satan's final deception I don't know
where you guys stand on this issue I
hope this is eye opening for you but I
truly believe that Satan right now is
setting up the false Antichrist and it's
Trump and right now he's fitting all the
markers and because of this video this
is the start of people who even voted
for him saying I wish I would have never
voted for you and I'm starting to see
something in you that I don't like and
people are starting to put the pieces
together and I think more and more
people are going to start calling him
out as the Antichrist and when he's
identified as the Antichrist
the stage is being set for Satan to
appear as the cosmic Christ a
supernatural being who's going to put an
end to what Trump is doing whether
that's to put an end to Trump or his
system or whatever but then he's going
to unroll this false system of peace and
safety and a Revival what looks like a
true Revival but it's really a
co-exist uh one world religion and if
you stand on Truth thus sayth the Lord
The Ten Commandments if you do not budge
from What God Says in his Ten
Commandments you will be Public Enemy
Number One you will be locked away you
will be persecuted and finally you will
be beheaded because you are a discordant
note in this perfect Utopia of a coexist
one world religion and you're just some
extremist Zealot that needs to be put
away because you're
causing chaos in our perfect world
that's what's soon to come I hope this
is eye opening if it was please share
this with your family and friends please
give this a thumbs up and like it it
really helps get this video out into the
algorithm I think this is such a vital
important message right now and so many
people are talking about this video
because it just happened today but
nobody is talking about this angle so
please share this please subscribe we
can't do this without you if you want to
support this ministry you can do so by
going to candid truth.org we really need
your support because we stepped away in
faith from a steady paycheck to do this
just for you guys and we've been doing
this for eight months now and God has
provided through people like you if you
want to uh get a t-shirt that helps us
out too we get about $5 per shirt that
sells and we make these designs that are
just telling you it's cool to use your
brain that the truth will set you free
love is kind and a lot of other options
out there we can't do this without you
guys we love you God bless you we'll see
you next time on candid truth